die kamera darüber das wäre dann aber
abgesprungen
also man film vorgesehen ist auf regeln
er macht was er will was willst du
machen filme zählen wir über dieses
lernen
ich habe schon drei filme geschrieben
und sagt ihr film im kopf überall wohin
diese stoffe die davon handeln wir den
menschen träume wie ihre träume kaputt
wir sehen das entstehen dieses
erstaunlichen umfassenden irgendwie aber
nie zu ende gekommen werkes wir sehen
den frühen tod mit 37 jahren dieses an
beiden enden brennenden oskar roehler
hat einen film über rainer werner
fassbinder gedreht keinen dokumentarfilm
sondern einen spielfilm
das hätte furchtbar schief gehen können
wenn fassbinder hat natürlich selbst 40
filme gedreht und noch ein dutzend
theaterstücke geschrieben er hat
sozusagen den mythos den er hinterlassen
hat auch selbst erzeugt und die
vorstellung ist irgendwie mit diesen 40
mit dem gesamtwerk mit diesem gewaltigen
die nachlass aufnehmen zu wollen kann
eigentlich gut vorkommen aber du musst
doch wissen wo du schneiden richtung
verarschen ich bin ein fernsehmann
menschen fertig geschnitten aber es hat
geklappt unerwarteter weise vielleicht
für mich erwartete weise denn ich traue
ihm das zu
er ist zwar selbst ein enfant terrible
des deutschen films sowie er seine film
jetzt komfortable genannt hat aber er
wird mit aufgaben fertig die man anderen
nicht anvertrauen würde los worauf
wartet ihr kommt nicht jeder um bauch
los los los
ich habe keine zeit zu verlieren das
geheimnis dieses gelungenen films ist
wie oft eine budget not er hatte nicht
genug geld um den film im freien mit
großen kulissen zu drehen mit vielen
drehorten und hat sich deswegen in ein
studio zurückgezogen und dort hat er die
welt dass rainer werner fassbinder so
nachgestellt wie sie in dessen filmen
eigentlich auch erscheint nämlich als
treibhaus als abgeschlossenen kosmos als
käfig der leidenschaften begierden des
sadismus der ausbeutung und
selbstausbeutung in dem die menschen
sich genauso gegenseitig beflügeln wie
sie sich auch wieder kaputt machen
ich habe das mal auf wenn ich mal nicht
ein stück daraus ein stück der hand
stück du miststück die trotzigen tränen
des rheiner von werner so müsse
oliver matschie als hauptdarsteller
sieht fassbinder erstaunlich ähnlich vor
allen dingen wie dem späten fassbinder
und das hat einen effekt der ebenfalls
gut ist denn schon als junger regisseur
und damals noch schauspieler hat er
sozusagen das gesicht des späteren des
älteren und er wirkt also wie jemand der
niemals jung war und auch das passt sehr
gut zu fassbinder was sehen wir
ansonsten wir sehen die clique die
gemeinde mit der sich umgeben hat seine
schauspielerinnen seine geliebten
dargestellt in symbolischen figuren
nicht mit den wirklichen namen und eine
teilweise und wir bekommen ein gefühl
für die flugbahnen dieses erstaunlichen
kometenhaft verglühenden talents
deswegen ist dieser film ein lichtblick
vielleicht der lichtblick des deutschen
kinos in diesem jahr hat gerade die
stabilen was das heißt